globally recognized defenders of Human
Rights under one roof at the European
Parliament for a conference to share
ideas and advanced action the meeting of
this hour of prize network brought
together past laureates and included and
South Haida wife of the current winner
the jailed Saudi blog arrived by da way
mr. decibel yarn is not the green I
thought among nodes nama and including
xiamen from saudi army and saw a
paleontology ow hamid ali only divided
up for bidding who finds us human rights
are a big part of the work of parliament
which discusses abuses around the world
every month we need megaphone diplomacy
and not just silent diplomacy we need
the spoken word to the outside we need
to tell the regime's that someone is
listening not least in Russia whose
civil rights organization memorial won
the prize in 2009 mausoleum Watson yeah
pretty lunesta mean his name's Thomas
goat cheese Ojo the chilis god he knows
noggin silly dear Basilius miss Donna
odd name is dr. immediate Owasco
personality negative Novartis couple of
us with us key themes included human
rights and the digital age sectarianism
and the value of silent vs. megaphone
diplomacy